dai siti finalmente i nuovi disegni di
che il pitcher non vediamo l'ora di
vedere come faranno i novissimi scherzi
anche voi lo adora vi piace tantissimo
se non avete visto gli scorsi episodi
andati poi a vederli orecchini di oggi
abbiamo due joystick in tema con il
gameplay e lasciate subito un mi piace
sta non lasciatevi piace il prossimo
anno la vostra insegnante sarà schemi e
quindi mi piace questo dovete tipico di
preti downgrade qua il nuovo capitolo
special choc du barry sports media
quindi immagino che ci sarà scheri
teaser che fa abbiamo già vedere nelle
immagini scheri teaser che fa box o no
marco vallora mi fa troppo ridere perché
l'iter qualsiasi cosa faccia a tutti
vediamo quali sono allora abbiamo riso
di ho visto un point sembra che faccio
io con l'arco e guai a una china molto
pericolosa per il primo che poi le dosi
di scary teacher con il tiro con l'arco
hanno bisogno di un aggiornamento che
succede
[Musica]
poverino che cosa deve sopportare
francis di now praticamente dal melone
vuole passare alla noce pellicola più
difficile fino colpire in testa frey
ecco perché sto scappando allora fece un
rito trovo un modo per far sbagliare
scheri teaser quindi che non prenda
laddove ma in testa differenza deve
mancare il bersaglio mancare il
bersaglio
povero paura non vorrei essere nei suoi
panni
ho dimenticato di dire se non mi seguite
ancora tu mi stai ramagli inseguirvi
ovviamente il nome di testori su
tavolette seguito mi sa che tutti stop
che le è seduta sul divano ne possiamo
esplorare siamo nella sua camera da
letto
cos'è questo è una cosa nuova qualcosa
chiuso a chiave nel bagno cosa c'è
scritto trova la chiave di questa
vetrina sembrano delle lenti a contatto
sì perché c'è scritto nr
left right sinistra destra quindi ho
capito dobbiamo cambiare le lenti a
contatto così diventati forse crede poco
sotto a causa di ciò che sta il primo
aiuto aiuto aiuto ma non si stanca mai
di cena farò in modo che non mi
disturberà e mai più vista che l'abbiamo
già fatta arrabbiare porta sono quale
chiave nessun altro filo di chiavi co
sopra guarda se la chiave in più e
argentata ma non riesco a prenderla da
qui o no al momento trovà qualcosa per
riuscire a prendere la chiave è una
sedia uno sgabello ma la sede non me lo
fa ho dato scampo ma che parlando siamo
riusciti a nascondersi gonfiore in tempo
dobbiamo trovare una specie di sedia sì
ho un ultrà bello qualcosa per
raggiungere la chiave e remo se c'è
qualcosa qua fuori magari un cantina in
cantina è vero perché a volte scherzi
saper nascondere le cose in cantina
quarta che c'è una scala perfette
aspetta però non fu strano questa cosa
sta scolando ma sede olio qui ci sono
delle nei pezzi di legno me la fa
prendere la scatola con gli sci agiafro
allora c'è scritto che qui dobbiamo
tagliare i pezzi di legno quindi di
trovare qualcosa per tagliare i pezzi di
legno per poi prenderlo il casello per
poi prendere la chiave per poi attaccare
si sta diventando sempre meno non le sto
già scendendo dimmi che abbiamo il
giardino vediamo di trovare qualcosa per
tagliare collegno non lo so se c'è
qualcosa e sono tavoli nino rota qui c'è
qualcosa nascosto dietro all'albero
un'ascia un eroe l'altro episodio che
c'era lascia direttamente l'ha lasciata
lì mi riguarda dice di prendere la scala
a pioli quindi quella che abbiamo visto
prima quindi dobbiamo ritornare john
probabilmente con questo riusciremo a
tagliare il legno siamo quindi va bene
abbiamo preso una scala via possiamo
prendere la chiave adesso mi resta
quando si pensò che si arrivava
brighiamo si sta entrando proprio qui
scritti essere diventata più brava ora
si rende subito conto se ne siamo
entrati in casa reyer proprio lì vicino
la porta d'entrata aggiunto è diventato
bravissimo voglio scappare
non possiamo prendere le cose sta
andando girato ci mettiamo subito la
scala qui
ok sistema è che succede ormai non
riesco a prenderla
c'è una macchia d'olio qui fatto perché
ci sono quei bidoni sopra allora
dobbiamo trovare qualcosa per pulire
quell'olio che l'edizione diventata
cattivissime bravi si sta benissimo cosa
andremo a prendere e quindi mette ancora
più cose per ostacolarsi cosa possiamo
prendere per per pulire quell'odio qui
ho visto un telo se non sbaglio qui in
piscina
nessuna mano si un telo da bagno eccolo
ok o guarda c'è scritto usano sulla
scala azioni per prendere la chiave mi
dispiace per te feriti sono anche se
questa volta sesta da mosto figura bar
vinceremo noi ci proviamo quindi usiamo
il telo sulla macchia d'olio qui si non
pulito la macchia d'olio e alle sono le
chiavi e non le fa prendere succede
perché non me ne può prendere o no è
un'altra trappola o no non sta già
arrivando perché non ci fa prendere
liberare ho fatto tutto
mi chiamo che ora non si accorga dello
scopo riproviamo speriamo che questa
volta corruzioni allora si possa dire
piano piano questa volta l'abbiamo presa
forse era un ruolo o non è perciò visto
ha detto dall'altra senza lasciarci fare
[Musica]
lei non si stanca mai quando giriamo in
forno più basso forse ha perso le tracce
adesso dobbiamo ritornare in quel
bagnetto lì o no abbiamo finito
l'energia più nei verdi read avete
bruciato dall'altra che magari possiamo
prendere nel frattempo che lei non c'era
tutto ok meno male ci siamo ricaricati
però adesso dobbiamo andare qui in bagno
non la dice di prendere le lenti di
missili vediamo che abbiamo aperto che
le prese le menti
sentinella salta tipica lato messo così
mancava incassano la salsa piccante
parola bidente sarà in cucina ma
potrebbe anche diventare ceca così non
si addice di rimettere elementi a posto
giustamente li mettiamo
come reagirà ci mettiamo le a posto
prima che se ne accorga auspichiamoci se
si succedono come si possono come leggi
e altri quando voi spiriti serre questo
scherzo davvero male
rimettiamo le lenti chiudiamo la porta
allora dice attento che lei non se ne
accorga siamo anche lucchetto giusto
perché è sempre più furba eccola che fa
ginnastica guardati con la sorella
quando bhagirathi che sa che dobbiamo
mettere anche la chiave a posto perché
vede che c'è da ha ridato anch'io lo
rimetto a posto così mentre morge warba
e attenta ad ogni dettaglio steri
teacher
no mi sa che mi è caduto perché non ho
fatto in tempo a mettere la chiave
purtroppo il gioco si era bagnato perché
siccome scarichi search of praise è
sparita la chiave quindi abbiamo il dato
riferito a cena calo ho promesso a
scappare subito in modo che non ci
prende altrimenti ho paura che si
bambina di nome non vedo l'ora di vedere
cosa succederà allora bisogna bisogna
rimettere tutto a posto compreso anche
la chiave alle nostre cose di tutto è
stato puro
ho preso l'estintore
non c'è riuscito a bruciare rosa sulla
testa di francis intergraph a tavola
vuole mostrare le sue capacità nel
tirare lasciano dalla piana della cia
che dovrebbe sapere che termini che si
veda in inglese ed italiano come si può
tradurre che quello galan ct ritorno
indietro e quindi già un sospetto un
tubetto di quello che succederà
poi c'è un cappello da vichingo ecco
perché c'era lasciali prima si faceva
francis con un magnete in mano ho capito
perché è per far tornare indietro lascia
lui latina con il magnete che cos'è
questo la macchina di francis un altro
in canna allora facciamo un giro vediamo
che cosa c'è di nuovo allora sotto il
tappeto ci dovrebbe essere la chiave
vediamo ma questa è una chiave verde
aprirà questa porta
non penso proprio ha cambiato lucchetto
che dice vediamo allora facciamoci un
giro vediamo che cosa troviamo di nuovo
comunque scheri tease per il cappello ed
ambiti dove ormai sembravano che mette
vitale
non mi è proprio li aiuta il kkk siamo a
scappare dalla cantina primo che non
abbia messo delle trappole nola chiuso
addirittura che tutto è diventata super
attenta cosa sono queste delle boccette
delle bombolette 21 presa una questo che
cos'è dentro e fuori
mettiamolo su alto è uscito scritto
aspetta che francis tolta la giacca
attento non farti cadere non nascondersi
per chiedere togo era quello lite
sembrava ieri un termostato tipo del
delle temperature per i termosifoni e
quindi l'ho messo su alto per l'ultima
tiziano fuori fatti non lo so perché ho
frainteso che si toglie la giacca c'è
scritto qualcosa nave della giacca di
brandy ok ok attento che scrivere lì dai
[Musica]
sono le chiavi della macchina dei
francesi ecco perché c'era la macchina
dovremo prendere dalla dice di aprire il
cofano della macchina
ok dice di mettere mai in maniera nel
casco nemmeno al metodo davvero vichingo
forza capito penso di aver capito come
andrà questo scherzo dobbiamo mettere il
magnete nell'elmetto di scary teaser poi
scritti permetterà nel mezzo da vichingo
tirerà lasciargli arriverei resta alla
la metto da vichingo non lo so dobbiamo
cercarlo eccolo qui c'è l'elmetto da
vichingo abbiamo questo magnete beatrice
di pitturate del metto io ci amiamo
questa rosa ma dice di andare via però
aspetta
aiuto abbiamo trasformato nel metto in
casa che carino apprezzerà misti e
vediamo se non scappiamo tanto ma mi
sono iscritto rosa perché i capelli di
misti sono sacri per lei che dei capelli
non ci credo è stato troppo divertente
sento come gli asili o tagliati i
capelli il teaser prevedere il
rapidissimo
secondo me quest'ultimo perché le civile
troppo i capelli e così non lascia non
fate all'americano super divertente bene
perché erano i due nuovi livelli di
scritti sempre stato il vostro livello
preferito il vostro momento preferito
scrivetelo
ora vi lasciamo che ha fatto cappellini
cercare per vedere i nostri altri video
tra cui gli altri livelli di ungaretti
di serre cade su quella che preferite
buona visione ciao